okay
so we have uh some sort of real opus
here
let's see what he will go for
oh yeah i think i had this against him
before
it's interesting
this one
formula these lines with bishop
c5 are not very popular not they're not
considered very good
question of course is where you play
against them
because when you play these lines that
have been sort of
have been so unpopular and
generally rejected by theory then
you can gain an advantage because people
don't know them
[Music]
i kind of want to put the bishop on g5
so i'm just going to do that
and he may at some point go h6 and
either [ __ ] b7 or
or g5 but in either case i think it's
good for me that the bishop is on b7
it would be better off going to c8 and
e6 possibly
or g4 so he's gone [ __ ] b7 immediately
which is surprising to
me this is i thought now my bishop could
also go the other way
so i would have thought it would be
better
to include h6 first but what do i know
okay let's just go c3
h6 i probably still have to go bishop f
h4
maybe we can trade and go bishop d5
yeah let's try it
looks reasonable
may end up in a situation where my
knight is better than this bishop
that's what i'm hoping at least and
for the moment feeling
that my pieces are a little bit
a little bit more active here knight c2
d5 i probably just ignore 93.
this bishop is a little bit suspicious
so
i think i'm a little better
and even if i'm not
position is is easy to play no i'm
certainly a little better
even if it's it's not much it's easier
to to play and there's little
little risk and at this point
just trying to to do exactly that
put some little pressure on him and
just frustrate him by not giving him
a lot of chances to beat me now
intending knight g4
and okay
it makes sense to go h5 i guess
so i'll go rook to one attending d4
and he allows it interesting
can also make moves like this instead
possibly queen a2 or r1
so it's it's not like i'm forced to do
anything immediately but
probably wants to do this and this
so i have to do something at some point
please don't gain a whole lot by going
d4 ed for 94. he cannot take an e4
because of knight c6
but after queenie queen eight maybe i
don't have a whole lot there
maybe i do okay let's go
queen eight maybe i have ed 95 knight c6
couldn't win a pawn
b4 is an idea for him yeah this wasn't
great
this wasn't great but i i had to make a
move at some point
yeah b4 that's what i was worried about
see before there's c5
[Music]
too bad
we'll just have to retreat them no i'm
certainly not better anymore and it
should just be very very dry
just have to speed up a little bit so
that i die
that i don't that i don't
uh lose the game unnecessarily
yeah this wasn't this wasn't very good
could have handled this a lot better
do i have knight c6
no i can't say that i do
okay i think regardless of what he'd
gone for there it's
pretty dry and droish
yeah i just need to make sure that i
don't blunder
let's go knight to 5 93 maybe
yeah roxy five okay he just he just
trades
push bay five is the only move but it's
quite sufficient
try it even more
and i think draw
okay halfway there